almost everyone is heading
you know a family member
who suffers from heart disease or his
hand heart disease or has sudden cardiac
death and so just trying to get them to
understand that there is a relationship
between your lifestyle
and your outcome just make that
connection if we could do that we would
all be so so much better off nutrition
is the most important decision that we
can make and so for the individual
patient finding out where they are and
seeing what are the elements that are
going to create more more and more
diseases similar to what brought them to
my office in the first place and and I I
understand that this this is not Primary
Care this is not Family Practice not you
know these are people who already have
heart disease when they're seeing me and
so I have a little easier job because
they're already motivated the fact that
they're in my office means that they're
motivated to try to make some kind of
change they're expecting to come out of
there with something different that's
going to change their outcome